c'est une annonce qui pourrait bien
embrasé le proche orient
pour bien comprendre il faut revenir au
début de l'année en janvier donald trump
raison de ce qu'il considère comme un
plan de résolution du conflit israélo
palestinien
ce plan paix américain très
favorablement accueilli par le premier
ministre d'israël benyamin nétanyahou
ouvre la voie à l'annexion de la vallée
du jourdain et des colonies de
cisjordanie
le projet est immédiatement rejetée par
le hamas au pouvoir dans la bande de
gaza mais aussi par mahmoud abbas
président de l'autorité palestinienne
pour la branche militaire du hamas ce
plan ne constitue ni plus ni moins
qu'une déclaration de guerre la
résistance considère cette décision
d'annexion de la cisjordanie et de la
vallée du jourdain comme une déclaration
de guerre contre notre peuple
palestinien la résistance dans cette
guerre sera un gardien fidèles de ce
peuple et de ses lieux saints pourquoi
ce plan est s'il difficilement
acceptable pour les palestiniens
morcelée et amputé d'une partie
conséquente de son territoire
l'état palestinien serait alors réduit à
la portion congrue le plan entérinerait
également l'installation de la capitale
de l'état hébreu à jérusalem et
renverrait la capitale d'un état
palestinien aux faubourgs de la ville
trois fois sainte
en outre s'il était mis à exécution ce
plan fut murray au pied l'ensemble des
négociations et accords internationaux
qui maintiennent ces deux régions du
proche orient dans un équilibre précaire
depuis plus de 50 ans pour comprendre le
choc que représenterait son application
il suffit de se pencher sur quelques
cartes jusqu'à l'arrivée de donald trump
à la maison blanche les négociations
entre l'état hébreu et les autorités
palestiniennes se basait sur la ligne
verte les frontières qui existaient
avant la guerre des six jours de 1967
au lendemain de cette guerre qui avait
vu la victoire de l'armée israélienne
sur les armées égyptiennes jordaniennes
et syrienne le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies avait adopté une
résolution pour la fin immédiate de
l'occupation militaire israélienne
sur les territoires palestiniens en se
référant à ses frontières
cette carte est depuis une référence
dans les négociations de paix elle a
notamment été utilisé comme base de
négociation pour les accords d'oslo en
aujourd'hui et en vertu des accords
d'oslo la cisjordanie et dit viser une
zone à placer son contrôle palestinien
où l'on trouve des principaux centres
urbains palestiniens une zone b sous
contrôle mixte et une zone c contrôlées
exclusivement par les israéliens et où
se trouvent les colonies israéliennes
dont l'implantation s'est amplifié
depuis l'arrivée de netanyahou au
pouvoir
c'est cette zone c'est qu'israël cherche
à annexer et qui représente 60% du
territoire
comme on peut le voir sur la carte 8 et
par donald trump est sobrement intitulé
viviane for peace entendait une vision
pour la paix l'état palestinien serait
considérablement réduit
on notera également la présence sur
cette carte dans tunnel reliant la
cisjordanie à la bande de gaza ainsi que
deux zones implanté dans le territoire
désertique du néguev au sud d'israël
l'une à vocation industrielle l'autre
agricole et qui serait sous contrôle
palestinien pour le premier ministre
israélien qui entame son cinquième
mandat
le plan trump offre une opportunité
historique de faire valoir la
souveraineté de l'état hébreu ce plan
pourrait pourtant avoir des conséquences
désastreuses d'ailleurs selon un sondage
publié au début du mois
une majorité d'israéliens ont craint une
nouvelle intifada en cas d'annexion et
pourtant le président américain continue
de croire que son accord du siècle
permettra de faire un grand pas vers la
paix et on serait tenté de dire qu'il
est bien l'un des seuls